ciao a tutti allora dopo un lungo
soggiorno parigino salto dal giffoni
intorno finalmente possesso della mia
videocamera e faccio subito un video ci
sono riuscito
in parole povere mi sono dato un momento
di riposo fatto di ore e ore di dormita
nullafacenza e carbonara luogo di mia
madre ma la pacchia è finita
avete forse notato qualcosa lo so e non
tipo i secoli che la volevo è finalmente
quando sono tornato a casa l'ho trovata
nella mia buca delle lettere e sono
impazzito
adesso la amo la mia maglietta ci farei
di tutto qualsiasi cosa ci dormirei cqc
nelle uova scia delle bottiglie c e
spremere gli agrumi ci farei pure un
calendario
[Musica]
comunque ricevere questa maglietta mi ha
fatto capire una cosa che la vita è
fatta è fatta di occasioni di talento di
bravura di essere la giusta verso nel
momento giusto
devi lottare per avere quello che vuoi
se vi compete ma se ci si mette la sfiga
ma la spiega non esiste cioè è solamente
un alibi per i nostri problemi è un
alibi per le nostre cavolate un insieme
di coincidenze niente di più cioè
esistono 2000 superstizioni che non sto
nemmeno ad elencarvi o forse sì che ben
si sposa
[Musica]
grazie mille per i governi non hanno
solo io sono così emozionata
[Musica]
[Applauso]
fermi un attimo scuotere i tasti
basta insomma il minuto lasciando le
puzzano le sale berto
[Applauso]
chi ti sporchi tranquilla teli genito io
grazie
[Applauso]
allora tu non prendo sto meglio
scusate qualcuno ha visto il vino
[Musica]
ok ragazzi fin qui mi sento io a nando
che so già scusata
insomma di fare l'amore in un lago
lasciarmi in può andare o qualcosa di
più romantico non so non lo so guarda
safari con corsi e non posso quindi
affascinantissimi indigeni la morale
della storia è che la sfiga non esiste
cioè siamo noi gli artefici del nostro
destino appare per mio cioè siamo noi
quelli che decidono quando vale la pena
smettere
e quanto invece vale la pena combattere
e poi va in ogni caso cioè non so se
avete notato che io e tutto quello che
ho fatto nel video l'ho fatto per
davvero enorme successo tipo
assolutamente nulla
guglielmo è pronto che fai bene a tavola
ok